they give you this setup pretty standard
sort of proportionality so it's actually
not a modified situation at least not
yet
but they're slightly mean in that they
say K is negative that's a pain isn't it
hey they give you this equation but they
actually stay at the case negative which
is very odd that's very very unusual but
what does it mean
you can actually tell me what it means
if K is negative it sort of implies a
negative sign here right so what's
happening to the population it's it's
decreasing and when you read the next
sentence that makes sense it says it for
the population Hobbs in three years the
population harmed in three years okay
now before I account for that if this is
the situation I have got right it's not
modified so it's a standard and equals a
K T and normally we would write it as
minus K T indicating that it's decaying
right but they have accounted for the
negative up here
okay so just kind of in your mind's eye
see that the negative really is there
now if that's the kind of situation
right they haven't given us any
information yet about the initial
population which will be a-okay so it
seems probably but we can still account
for me information they give us if we
think about the fact that we're two to
zero the population will just be a right
because this will be in the north so
just be one so therefore I can still say
even though I don't know what the number
is when T equals three after three years
right the population will be half of
whatever it started with okay so this is
kind of like the half-life situations
which is almost exactly like the
half-life situations when you're looking
of any radioactive metals that kind of
thing so I can use this I can pop
everything straight in and get a value
for K right watch I'll get a on - that's
my population up that's what equals a e
to the three there's more time okay
there you go now beating you've got the
toward a factor of eight on both sides
you just divide through by that and then
you take logs
okay so you don't need to know what the
initial population is in order to work
out how quickly it's dropping down okay
because the information they've given us
that tells us about the rate at which it
declines okay I should tidy this up okay
is equal to okay which is a negative
number now you go to your calculator and
you evaluate that and you get out of
decimal zero zero point two three one
bla bla bla bla
okay now this number is important this K
is so important that they actually call
this this is confusing they call this
the growth rate that's been weed isn't
it it's weird to talk about this thing
as if it has a growth rate because we
know the growth rate is changing
constantly okay but the idea is that
this this thing is what defines how
quickly or slowly it happens if I made
it a smaller number it would be decaying
slower and if I made a bigger negative
number it would be dropping off really
quickly so this number really does
define the speed at which the population
declines and that's why they call it the
growth rate okay so being that it's a
decimal that's the real weird way to say
it they asked for it as a percentage so
all you have to do is multiply by a
hundred and you get approximately
negative twenty three percent you do
have to say it's a negative because
they're calling it our growth rate it's
long as decline rate right so like I
said that's a bit weird but they're
choosing to use a negative value rather
than words to show you that the
populations drop it okay so there you go
there's the growth rate of negative
twenty three percent to the nearest
percent anyway estimate the population
of the Colonia after five years if and
now they give you an initial condition
okay so if the population is 250 to
start with okay and it doesn't have to
be but they're just giving that as
Lemone
Yeah right we can pop this back into
yeah this is where I wrote it okay
because we know what K is we've already
evaluated it and we know what a is
because then just provide it to us okay
so if that's the case and they want
after five years you just crunch the
numbers so let's give it a go
your population will be 250 e ^ let's
see I think for me personally I did it
like this because I just don't like
putting so many things in the power it's
a bit awkward it's more buttons to push
so when you get that I think you end up
with seventy eight point something which
is your 79 okay by the way this is a
good point for me to mention the whole
deal with rounding up and rounding down
especially when you've got objects I
mean pretty much always have objects why
what is this what are they there what
are they what animals are they are that
we don't even know their animals or some
description okay now you might be
inclined to say Oh seventy eight point
seven four but you can't have point
seven four over an animal so you might
think oh ok I should round down okay now
when you have a look at the question the
thing is there's nothing in the question
that indicates to you that you need to
round it to that whole number especially
when you realize this number is dropping
it's dropping right so it hasn't got to
78-year does that make sense I'm
watching this number decrease over time
and when it hits seventy eight point
zero that's when I would predict
okay there's 70 animals left right at T
equals five I'm not at 78 yet I'm still
above it so even though the model
predicts you know not whole numbers I
think I'm still up here okay just as a
general guide if you're if you're ever
unsure about should I go up or should I
go down okay go up or down but say what
you're doing right you would say to the
nearest animal and the most common place
where you would explain I'm rounding
down or up you've not unusual is where
you're rounding the wrong way if I did
round this down if I rounded to on 78
okay because that's not the normal way
we round 0.74 I'm sort of obliged to say
something to indicate I know what's
going on and then I'm not just bad at
rounding okay so if you ever sort of
unclear about is it up or down your best
course of action is just actually say
what you're doing and why okay there's
part a this pilot will part one rather
now part two then they aren't they
change the rules who came and they say
okay now let's look at it as a modified
situation okay so they give you this
differential equation you have to verify
that this new equation that they provide
to you which is claimed of them that
this equation slots into there so all
you have to do is differentiate then
you'll get that out don't integrate it's
not the way to go and then they say what
can be deduced about M and DN on DT as T
increases so they're saying as time goes
to infinity okay well he's our n
equation right so if we take that limit
what do you get what's happened to this
guy don't forget K is negative K is
actually there's a negative hiding in a
minute right so what happens to e to the
KT it becomes this tiny tiny tiny number
right so this guy vanishes so you just
get left with 50 okay something I
skipped in the previous part was that if
you think about the limit here it just
drops off it goes off to zero as you
would expect that this function does
okay so that's that limit you can also
think about the limit of the derivative
what happens here well I know what's
happening to n right I know what's
happening to n it's going toward 50 so
what's happening to n minus 50
it's going to what zero isn't it so the
whole thing is going toward 0 because K
is just the constant [ __ ] so what this
tells you is that it's leveling off to a
sort of um 250 and it's so stabilizing
there ok now what do they want to keep
doing they want us to repeat this
process of finding the growth rate for
this situation okay so I've got to bring
back my initial conditions find a new
value for K so I'm going to take the
same piece of information but use it on
a different equation okay so I'll say
when T equals 3 and they actually do
start giving you numbers right away the
population is going to be half okay so I
can pop that into here oh no I should
have popped eat with you in first sorry
when T equals zero you start with that
because as you remember when it's
modified the C's not just going to be
250 is it I think in this case is going
to be 200 yes jumpy did show you how
that works
oh yeah yeah okay let's do it 250 equals
50 plus there's that C which I do not
know that's either K T which is just
zero because it's time zero so this is
just B gonna become C bring the 50 over
the other side that's where your 200
pops out okay to find K I need some
other point in time which is where I'll
do this
okay so I've got 125 over here 50 here I
just put 200 there like so okay so I'll
bring this over that's 75 I managed all
divided by 200 one line that's it
steady comma 200 take out 25 25 3 over 8
so now skipping a couple steps because
you can see what's going to happen here
I'm going to get a value of K equals
let's see a third still log three on 8
so slightly off I mean this is for inane
isn't it and this is 300 so is this
quicker or is it slower
what's the number you can actually get
the decimal out again you get a negative
because the population is still decaying
and I think you get 0.33 something
something yes so you're getting negative
33%